bonjour thomas les 17 députés les filles
ont donc déposé un amendement pour
réclamer un moratoire contre ce projet
du milliardaire américain
oui ces députés se pose en effet une
forme de privatisation celle de l'espace
le milliardaire
elon musk concret vous l'avez dit une
constellation de satellites en orbite
autour de la terre afin de fournir un
service internet à l'ensemble de la
planète mais voilà que les députés
insoumis s'y opposent les membres de
ceux du groupe parlementaire de la
france insoumise ont profité de l'examen
du projet de loi de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique afin de mettre ce
sujet sur la table
concrètement voici ce qu'on peut lire
dans l'amendement en question un
moratoire sur le déploiement de starling
sur le territoire français est décrété
ce projet ne pourra être lancée qu'à la
condition d'un avis favorable de la
population française résultant d'une
consultation nationale menée à travers
tout le territoire français pendant au
moins un an
alors thomas quels sont les arguments
avancés par les députés alors plusieurs
points attire l'attention des
signataires de l'amendement d'abord il
ya le droit à l'obscurité les satellites
peuvent générer de la pollution
lumineuse et ainsi perturber le travail
des astronomes notamment est de plus en
plus compliqué d'observer le ciel sans
être gênés par les trajectoires des
satellites d'autres questions évidemment
concernant l'aspect écologique d'un tel
projet est évidemment très gourmand en
ressources naturelles et qui nécessitent
aussi l'installation d'antennes-relais
d'ailleurs certains élus locaux en
france s'oppose à ce projet pour cette
raison particulièrement et puis il ya le
risque de collision dans l'espace qui
pourrait être accentuée par le
déploiement titanesque prévu par la loi
de musc les équipes du milliardaire
américain ont déjà passé plusieurs
centaines de satellites en orbite et à
terme ce sont plusieurs milliers de ces
appareils qui pourraient graviter au
dessus de nos têtes le projet starlink
filiale du groupe space x pour être au
total réunir jusqu'à 42 mille satellite
de quoi augmenter les risques de
collusion de collision et de débris déjà
très nombreux surtout que d'autres
acteurs du marché dans la chine pourrait
vouloir eux aussi créé leur
constellation s'étaler de satellitaire
au moment où c'est un moment
a des chances d'aboutir thomas donc il
est assez peu probable que cet
amendement soit conservée par la
majorité mais il permettra au moins
d'ouvrir un débat à l'assemblée
l'autorité de régulation des télécoms
l'arcep avait déjà donné son feu vert en
février dernier pour une utilisation de
fréquences télécoms par l'entreprise
d'elon musk un premier pas vers un accès
aux services d'internet très haut débit
par satellite car le projet du
milliardaire américain de créer un
réseau mondial et finalement même si la
france refusait il ya fort à parier que
des milliers de satellites se lancer par
elon musk voleront quoi qu'il arrive au
dessus de nos têtes en clair nous
aurions de toute façon les inconvénients
sont les avantages toujours est il que
le débat existe sur ces question doit-on
laisser une entreprise privée la
possibilité de posséder une telle
technologie
à l'heure où l'espace se militarise où
la conquête spatiale relances parfois
des tensions géopolitiques
la question a au moins le mérite d'être
posée effectivement merci thomas pour
toutes ces précisions et on compte sur
vous pour suivre ce dossier de près